-For two days,
the nation was paralyzed
by an existential crisis,
the likes of which this country
has never seen,
a crisis so dire,
it threatened our institutions,
our political system,
our very way of life.
A waking nightmare that has left
us frightened and confused.
A watershed moment that has
changed America forever.
There was a balloon.
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
By now, no doubt, you've heard
about the Chinese spy balloon.
It flew across the
continental U.S.
and monopolized the media's
attention for days
and it made
an electrifying appearance
at last night's Grammys.
[ Laughter ]
Well, it electrified everyone
but Ben Affleck.
[ Laughter ]
How can you drink
that much Dunkin' coffee
and still look like
someone stole his bike?
[ Laughter ]
Anyway,
the balloon was all anybody
could talk about
after it was spotted
in the sky on Thursday
and made quite a trip
across U.S. airspace.
-The balloon has traveled
for days
from Western Alaska
to the Midwest.
-It traveled thousands of miles
across the United States.
-It started in Alaska,
Aleutian Islands, Alaska,
and then came
down through Canada
and it just crossed into the
United States in Montana.
-It was spotted here
in Billings Wednesday
and is still on the move
this morning,
hovering over the Northern U.S.
-The balloon is likely
somewhere over Kansas
after sightings
over Montana yesterday.
-It drifted across Nebraska
and then into the Midwest today,
spotted as it made its way
across Missouri.
-From Idaho to Montana,
all the way
down to the Carolinas.
-It was about six nautical miles
off the coast
near Myrtle Beach,
South Carolina.
-First of all, we should stop
calling it a Chinese spy balloon
when a far more accurate name is
[bleep] Chinese spy balloon.
[ Laughter ]
The only way this balloon
could've had a higher profile is
if it had its own
Instagram account.
[ Laughter ]
This balloon did more traveling
than a high school senior
taking a gap year
before college.
[ Laughter ]
True story -- it already has
Diamond Medallion status
on Delta.
[ Laughter ]
Next time it's spotted
in American airspace,
it's going to be in first class.
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
Writers all day were like,
"A balloon in a first-class seat
with a glass of champagne,"
and our graphics department
was like,
"Alright, [bleep] it,
I don't know
[ Laughter ]
what that looks like.
I feel like your job is way
easier than my job."
[ Laughter ]
There's something about it
being a balloon
that just makes it very hard
to take seriously.
Like it would be one thing
to send a fleet of fighter jets
or a giant naval vessel.
That would be scary.
But a balloon?
Are they trying to scare us
or cheer us up at the hospital?
[ Laughter ]
We should respond with something
even dumber to flummox them.
Like we should send one
of those air dancers they have
outside car dealerships...
[ Laughter ]
...you know, but undercover,
with a wig and a mustache.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I do like to imagine him
as a British spy working for MI6
in a joint operation
with the CIA.
[ English accent ]
Your mission is to infiltrate
the Chinese Army
and gather intelligence on their
most closely guarded secret.
You think you can handle that,
old chap?
"You've got it!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, the balloon thing was all
anyone could talk about
for days.
But it was an especially
big hit on Fox News,
whose human news balloons
could not stop
obsessing over it.
[ Laughter ]
-There is a Chinese spy balloon
floating over America right now.
-A high-altitude
Chinese spy balloon.
-There is, by the way,
a Chinese spy balloon.
-A Chinese by balloon.
-A Chinese spy balloon.
-Chinese spy balloon.
-Balloon.
[ Laughter ]
-An entire network
became obsessed
with the balloon,
like a five-year-old
at a birthday party.
[ Laughter ]
Just to screw with Fox News,
Biden should've announced
that he was inviting the balloon
to appear in this year's
Thanksgiving Day Parade.
[ Laughter ]
The speculation on the right got
so fevered and out of control
that Republicans
and Fox personalities
started taking wild guesses
about what might be
inside the balloon.
-My concern is that
the federal government,
obviously, doesn't know what's
in that balloon.
Is that bioweapons
in that balloon?
Is it? Did that balloon
take off from Wuhan?
[ Laughter ]
-The next balloon might be
filled with another virus.
Pop!
Droplets all over.
We're all on ventilators again.
[ Laughter ]
-There's a lot
of devastating weapons
that could be delivered
this way,
to include
electromagnetic pulse, EMP.
-Did it drop and disperse
surveillance products
powered by solar energy
to allow unlimited surveillance?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
Probably not?
[ Laughter and applause ]
These people were so scared
of a balloon,
you would think it was floating
out of a sewer grate.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Bartiromo ]
Was it filled with a virus,
a bioweapon,
an electromagnetic pulse?
Did it drop solar-powered
surveillance products
in everyone's house,
so they can spy on you
while you drink box wine
and watch "Real Housewives"?
[ Laughter ]
Or maybe it's filled
with delicious candy,
piñata-style,
and, if that's the case,
[ Laughter ]
why isn't Biden
shooting it down?
Is he waiting for it
to drift over Delaware,
so he can keep all the candy
for himself?
[ Laughter ]
We deserve answers
and we deserve delicious candy!
[ Laughter ]
And yet, the dumbest
speculation was
the incessant questioning,
over and over,
of why Biden wouldn't just
shoot down the balloon
while it drifted
over the continental U.S.
-Why haven't we shot
this balloon out of the sky?
Oh, Joe Biden is the president.
-I can nearly guarantee you
that that balloon
would still not be flying,
if we were still there.
-Why did it take
U.S. officials
so long
to shoot it down?
-You have to wonder
why isn't our military
doing anything about it?
And it elicits
so many questions.
I think about Joe Biden.
Is Joe Biden compromised?
Is that why he won't allow
the military to do it?
There's a lot in that laptop
that might have something to do
[ Laughter ]
with this response as well.
-That's right,
they think Biden waited
to shoot down the balloon,
not because the debris
might crash on land
and potentially cause harm
or distraction to Americans,
but because
of Hunter Biden's laptop.
As far as I'm aware,
the only balloon associated
with Hunter's laptop is
the balloon who found it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
In their minds, what do they
think was going on here?
Biden's son Hunter was, somehow,
compromised by China,
so, in return,
Joe Biden made a secret deal
with the Chinese government
to allow them to fly a giant,
super visible, balloon
over the country for a few days
before shooting it down.
If that's the case,
I think it's actually
a terrible story for China
because that is a very bad deal.
"We've informed President Biden
of the dirt we have on his son.
He was willing to make a trade."
Excellent news.
What did we get?
Copies of top secret documents,
access to their nuclear secrets?
"No.
Something even better.
We got balloon access!
[ Laughter ]
Three days' worth!"
Alright, I think we need
a new negotiator.
[ Laughter ]
Also, you guys think Biden's the
one who's compromised by China?
Trump and his daughter Ivanka
had Chinese trademarks approved
while they were working
in the White House.
Trump had a business pursuit
and a secret bank account
in China.
In fact, Trump paid nearly
$200,000 in taxes to China
over several years,
while, in 2020,
he paid no income taxes
in the U.S.
And I know the right is upset
about the idea
that we would hire
more IRS agents,
but it does seem to say a lot
about our tax system
that Donald Trump
could easily evade taxes here,
but still had
to pay them in China.
[ Laughter ]
"Sir, we have to file our taxes
with the U.S."
[ As Trump ]
Tell them I owe them zilch.
They won't do [bleep].
It's just one guy
and he's so tired.
[ Laughter ]
"And what about China?"
[ As Trump ]
Oh, send them every penny.
[ Laughter ]
I would hate to lose access
to my TikTok account.
[ Laughter ]
I finally learned
all the dances!
[ Laughter ]
In fact, just to give you
an idea of how stupid
the right-wing discourse
about this balloon has been,
multiple GOP politicians,
from former Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo
to Congressman Paul Gosar,
to failed Arizona gubernatorial
candidate Kari Lake,
to Ohio Senator J.D. Vance
posted photos of themselves
pointing guns in the sky,
[ Laughter ]
implying that they
could shoot down the balloon
themselves.
My favorite one of these is
Yale-educated,
Silicon Valley venture
capitalist J.D. Vance cosplaying
as one of the dudes
from "Duck Dynasty."
[ Laughter ]
No one's buying
your shtick, dude.
Look at the freshly purchased
Bengals hoodie.
You just know the tag is still
on that.
[ Laughter ]
You look like a Hollywood
wannabe auditioning
for a remake of "Deliverance."
[ Laughter ]
And then, of course,
there are a bunch of Republicans
who claim the dumb balloon saga
would never have happened
under Donald Trump,
with some even going so far
as to claim that,
if it did happen, Trump would've
shot down the balloon
immediately.
Lauren Boebert tweeted...
And Marjorie Taylor Greene
tweeted...
Based on the kind words
Trump always had to say
about foreign adversaries,
I think,
if a Chinese spy balloon
had flown
over U.S. soil
during his presidency,
Trump would've tried
to befriend it.
He'd be telling stories about it
at his rallies to this day.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
When I was president,
I got along great
with all the floating vessels --
Zeppelins, airships, dirigibles.
[ Laughter ]
I love the dirigibles.
The dirigibles love Trump
and, of course --
[ Laughter ]
and of course, the balloon.
We love the balloon,
don't we, folks?
[ Laughter ]
I remember I was
in the Oval Office one day
when a Chinese spy balloon,
it floated down,
floated through the window.
Big balloon, strong balloon.
[ Laughter ]
Tears pouring
down its latex face
[ Laughter ]
and it said to me, it said --
[ Squeaking ]
[ Balloon farting ]
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "It's so true.
It's so true."
[ Laughter ]
But you know what?
They're right.
This would've never, ever, ever,
ever happened
under Donald Trump.
-U.S. officials tell Fox
it's not the first time
Chinese spy balloons have flown
over the United States.
About four months ago,
a Chinese spy balloon crashed
in the Pacific near Hawaii.
Others were spotted
over Texas and Florida,
dating back to the Trump
administration,
but never previously
acknowledged publicly.
-That's right,
they flew balloons under Trump.
Even worse,
they flew them at Mar-a-Lago.
[ Laughter ]
The incredibly dumb balloon
melodramas exposed
just how vacuous and silly
so much of the right-wing media
discourse is, these days.
They all lost their minds
over a balloon,
demanding that it be shot
down immediately
without any thought
of the potential consequences
and implying there was
some dark conspiracy at play.
And then, once Biden
did have it shot down,
he contradicted their talking
points and burst their...
-Balloon.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]